[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale du lundi 14 avril
le point déjà sur la propagation du
coronavirus dans les yvelines après une
légère baisse en fin de semaine dernière
le nombre d'hospitalisations est reparti
à la hausse dans le département
émile 70 personnes étaient hospitalisées
hier sur le territoire une légère
diminution des patients en réanimation
est toutefois à noter ils étaient 180 3
hier et depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire de 176 décès ont été recensés
dans les hôpitaux yvelinois
l'épidémie n'est pas encore maîtrisée
nous devons donc poursuivre nos efforts
et continuer d'appliquer les règles plus
elles seront respectées
plus nous sauverons de vie c'est pour
cela que le confinement le plus strict
doit encore se poursuivre jusqu'au lundi
11 mai la date est désormais connue le
confinement est prolongée jusqu'au 11
mai annonce des manuels macro et hier
dans son allocution aux français le 11
mai début du déconfinement donc
progressif avec air et ouverture des
crèches et des écoles mise en place d'un
masque grand public accessible pour
chaque français via les mairies
multiplication du nombre de tests pour
les personnes présentant des symptômes
du coït 19
écoutez la réaction d'une élue
yvelinoise alexandra rose étiez maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux est la date du 11
mai lui semble logique qu'elle attend
désormais un accompagnement de l'état
pour mettre en place le déconfinement
dans sa commune et dans les écoles pense
que c'est bien qu'il ya une date qui
soit posée et que ce soit pas dans 15
jours parce que on peut se projeter dans
le temps et commencer à réfléchir à ce
qu'on va mettre en place pour en sortir
moi je pense qu'effectivement il n'a pas
d'autre choix que de s'appuyer sur les
mers je trouverais ça normal que les
maires s'impliquent pour distribuer des
masques à la population pour aider à ce
déconfinement progressif que tout
devrait faire moins normal être obligé
de l'assumer financièrement
j'espère qu'on va être accompagné dans
la mise en place de cette future rentrée
je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on protège
en priorité bah tout le personnel qui va
graviter autour des enfants
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
stressant mais après il faut bien qu'on
en forte de ce confinement à un moment
ou un autre il ya quand même des enfants
qui n'ont pas forcément tous les mêmes
moyens d'accès je dirais aux au
numérique et donc ça crée forcément des
inégalités femmes hommes qui peuvent
alors le rôle social qu'on les écoles
quelques pas écouter à présent bertrand
guillon maire de la commune voisine de
magny les hameaux il ne retient pas de
grandes mesures de ce discours
présidentiel et préfère se concentrer
sur son rôle auprès des habitants c'est
un discours qui s'ajoute à d'autres
discours et la date du 11 mai est une
autre date comme d'otages ont été
annoncés auparavant
c'est pas une date d'annoncé sur un
déconfinement d'une date d'annoncé
jusqu'où va le confinement pour
l'instant maintenant si il y à d'autres
directives au niveau national nos
collectivités répondront présentes pour
pouvoir accompagner le mieux possible
les habitants en gardant toujours en
tête
certains aspects qui sont tout
simplement essentiel la santé des
personnels des personnes qu'on accueille
et surtout l'aide à l'ensemble des
familles et des personnes qui peuvent se
retrouver en difficulté annonces fortes
d'emmanuel macron c'est la réouverture
progressive à partir du lundi 11 mai des
crèches et écoles de la maternelle au
lycée une mesure qui en a surpris plus
d'un on va en parler avec deux invités
deux invités qui sont à distance manuel
afonso cancel bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
la secrétaire de dans les yvelines de la
fédération des parents d'élèves de la
paix et il ya également avec nous fabien
le duigou bonsoir vous faites le vous le
co secrétaire du snes effet suivi d'un
syndicat des enseignants du second degré
je vais vous faire d'abord réagir fabien
le duigou les modalités de cette reprise
des cours doivent être encore imprécises
et dans les 15 prochains jours a dit ce
matin le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer un même
si cette rentrée là dit elle ne se fera
pas comme avant ça se fera par petits
groupes
il y aura également un retour à l'école
kiné qui ne sera pas obligatoire a dit
ce matin j'en ai seulement car que
pensez vous de cette décision de reprise
progressive à partir du lundi 11 mai
alors là non ce qui a été dit hier soir
qui ont repris des couleurs et rumeurs
qui circulaient ce n'est pas d'aller pas
longtemps des drogues est si rapide
après mouche qui nous nous rend perplexe
et nous inquiète et dans les conditions
et leur entraînement
ne serait-ce que simplement par la
nécessité de gestev arrière dans
l'établissement là comment j à la
dépense depuis entre les élèves
la question du matériel et max donc
beaucoup beaucoup d'interrogations qu'on
est à la fois très ma passion d'antan
d'en savoir un peu plus c'est qu'ils
sont grands cris qui m'a précisé
et quand même état d'esprit les
enseignants qui aime beaucoup la vie
non pas leur âge ça près de ses
inquiétudes manuel afonso quand c'est la
décision du président de la république a
été motivé il l'a dit emmanuel macron
par la nécessité aussi de permettre le
retour à une activité professionnelle
des parents comment elle a été
accueillie cette décision de de
reprendre progressivement l'école à
partir du 11 mai ce très mitigé a en
fait suite aux annonces de monsieur
macron nous avons pris la liberté de
générer un sondage sur les réseaux
sociaux afin de prendre un peu la
température parce que justement on ne
sait pas trop comment réagir
on parle quand même de nos enfants qu'on
veut remettre à l'école dans des
situations sanitaires tels qu'on les
connaît aujourd'hui et qui nous inquiète
beaucoup
mais en même temps on est d'accord que
les foyers familiaux ont besoin de
travail et ont besoin de ramener de
l'argent
voilà la situation est assez assez
cocasse
en règle générale les parents sont
inquiets les parents ne sont pas pour un
retour au 11 mars
or 11 mais excusez moi qui paraît un peu
prématuré et surtout bon on garde aussi
en tête que à l'heure actuelle ce ne
sont que des annonces qu'il n'y a pas
encore de décision et de processus mis
en place en attendant du factuel en fait
on attend de voir ce que le factuel va
faire ressortir et mini 10 questions
nationales à 10,1 ce matin dans les 15
prochains jours en tout cas toutes les
les mesures les modalités seraient
connus pour cette reprise vous parliez
d'inquiétude manuel afonso cancel
notamment on l'évoquait
la difficulté de faire respecter des
gestes barrières aux enfants on a aussi
parlé de la question de la protection ne
sais pas encore aujourd'hui s'il y aura
des masques des gants qui seront mises
en place dans ces écoles tout à fait ça
va être très compliqué puis moi j'ai
vraiment une grosse pensée pour les
cours les enseignants et pour les
personnels d'encadrement en élémentaire
j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger avec avec
mes élus locaux sur l'organisation qui
est en images et surtout au premier
degré où c'est très compliqué pour des
enfants de maternelle et d'élémentaire
de respecter les mesures de
distanciation social principalement et
et puis on ne voit pas des élèves porter
un masque
toute la journée ou même une partie de
la journée ça va être très compliqué
pour les enseignants de réussir à ne pas
maintenir cette discipline autour de la
du sanitaire même les collectivités sont
inquiètes parce que il va falloir des
ressources humaines il va falloir
l'organisation la logistique qui ne
fonctionne pas forcément et ne serait-ce
que la cantine comment font les mais les
prestataires ne sont aussi en continuant
ne feront pas les bonnes raisons c'est
les mêmes inquiétudes on l'a compris
aussi du goût du côté des professeurs
savent bien le du goût mais alors nous
la première inquiétude à bord ça va être
de gérer en fait les premiers jours et
notamment nous d'ailleurs c'est m le
chsct ministériel à la vie qu'elle est
dotée de trois rives c'est qu'il est
nécessaire que tous les élèves tous les
personnels encadrants dont d'un
questionnaire soit dépistée
or on ne peut pas envisager une rentrée
sans un dépistage généralisé alors pour
le moment est venu maintenant et donc
évoqué des tests pour les personnes
seulement qui présentent des symptômes
pour l'instant ce n'est pas évoquée pour
les professeurs vous demandez que vous
qu'il ya des tests à plus grande échelle
qui soit mise en place
nous servons pendant que les jeunes
sourds souvent des porteurs un match
auquel ne développe pas les symptômes
donc ils peuvent très bien ramener du
coup le virus à l'établissement dans
l'établissement
il compte aller libérer les enseignants
ou au contraire aussi ont encore leur a
les cheveux ou pour nous là la condition
real à la première condition d'accès le
dépistage généralisé donc de tous les
passagers photo ddm
là c'est la sécurité là sans perdre donc
c'est sur ce point précis que vous allez
être vigilants là dans les 15 prochains
jours
je me disais un jean michel blanquer a
parlé de définition de modalités dans
les 15 prochains jours c'est sur ce
point précis là vous
vous allez être lundi dans une promenade
au site est dans la question
la distanciation sociale au collège a
présenté leur part classe au lycée 35
élèves par classe les salles de cours
qui sont tous remplis on pourra pas en
fait accueillir tous les élèves
je suis d'ailleurs persuadé que beaucoup
de familles ne doit pas pouvoir emmener
leurs enfants au collège outils dans les
écoles parce qu'ils vont donner encore
un dessin très bien que les conditions
d'accueil sont sound crew qui m'a fait
prendre un risque
il ya aussi cette question là des
effectifs par classe la actuellement on
a parlé de petits groupes
enfin le moyen serait de l'éducation
nationale a parlé de petits groupes ce
matin ce que c'est physiquement servent
aussi à moi pour des cibles de n'a pu
dire qu'une partie des délais il prendra
vie parfaite nous pas à garder les
enfants à la maison et mano la fronde au
concept sur quoi allez être vigilante
sur les prochaines les prochaines
semaines avant la première chose ça va
être les conditions qu'est ce qu'on
appelle une reprise progressive quelle
organisation
est ce que ça vaut vraiment le coup de
partir par petits groupes
est-ce qu'on est vrai ce qu'on est
vraiment sûr que ça va relancer une
activité économique
est ce que nos enfants vont être
accueillis dans de bonnes conditions
comme vous disiez tout à l'heure avec du
matériel en quantité suffisante et
surtout en utiliser les premiers faits
d'armes
et puis voilà on va être vraiment à
petit à petit les décisions qui vont
être prises
après on est bien d'accord que nous ne
sommes que des consultants dans
l'éducation nationale on ne peut que se
contenter d'exprimer les inquiétudes des
parents et c'est notre mission qu'on
assume aura jusqu'au bout mais là
l'objectif c'est vraiment que les choses
se fassent en toute intelligence en tout
en toute conscience et surtout de
ratures et je pense qu'on a on est dans
une situation assez anxiogène
on n'a pas besoin de s'en rajouter d'un
pardessus sauf que là on parle de nos
enfants donc il va vraiment falloir
réussir cette cet exercice de deux
d'organisation et de communication de
manière intelligente et efficace mais on
a compris vos réserves je voulais
terminer ses terres bio avec avec vous
fabien le duigou là en ce moment la zone
c est en vacances scolaires mais en tout
cas ça a été l'une des priorités l'une
des promesses affichées par l'éducation
nationale assure une certaine continuité
pédagogique est ce qu'elle a pu être
rassuré cette continuité pédagogique de
le début de ce confinement à leur gauche
dtp su ancrer un bilan très mitigé voire
négatifs de cette quantité pédagogique
en fait ce qu'on fait les enseignants
ont plutôt bien réussi c'est de
maintenir un lien pédagogique
effectivement les manières dans une
logique de travail en contact avec eux
mais on va pas pleurer
on ne travaille pas de la même façon
dispense et et on sait très bien aussi
d'ailleurs plusieurs sociologues qui
sont déjà interdits dans l'éditeur pour
d'évoquer que les élèves qui font
habituellement des scolaires en place le
classique le sont encore davantage en
fait c'est donc cette continuité
pédagogique nous est demandé par les
ministres en fait des multiples
inégalités en est encore en cours n'ont
aucun argument assez sévères même si
effectivement les élèves ont fait ce
qu'ils pouvaient les professeurs en fait
mais pour nous rien ne vous en faites un
enseignement classique en présentiel et
la prenez les plus efficaces et elle
était là et bien merci pour vos réponses
vos réactions fabien le duigou co
secrétaire du snes fsu des yvelines et
merci également à amman où il affronte
socke en scène un secrétaire de la pépie
vie n'est d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
dire que la pep mise en place depuis le
début de ce confinement une une page
consacrée impôts occuper les enfants
leur donner des idées d'activités
pendant le confinement merci à vous deux
merci à vous
29e jour de confinement en france et
dans les yvelines cette période qui va
donc se prolonger d'un mois
supplémentaire ce qui pousse certaines
entreprises à repenser leurs activités
c'est le cas de plaisir fruité installée
dans la zone industrielle de trappes
elle est spécialisée dans la livraison
de fruits au bureau dorénavant c'est aux
particuliers qu'elle s'adresse si elle
pourrait bien revoir durablement son
mode de fonctionnement
wilfrid richy et patrick jacques de
dixmude 1000 entreprises abonnés mais du
jour au lendemain une activité réduite à
zéro pour l'entreprise plaisir fruité le
confinement a été synonyme d'une mise au
chômage partiel de sa trentaine de
salariés mais une fois passé les
premiers jours de résignation ses deux
fondateurs ont trouvé une autre solution
le 16 mars
bah tout a changé puisque au début on
pensait devoir fermer la société puisque
nos clients sont uniquement des bureaux
donc tous en télétravail tout le monde a
arrêté donc on a on a décidé du coût
pour le client qui restait de fermer la
société on s'est converti à la livraison
aux particuliers
donc bon c'était un domaine qu'on ne
l'est pas du tout jusqu'à présent c'est
vraiment que du 8 au 10 et là on est
passés donc en be to see et on a fait
également un petit peu de ventes en
direct ici dans l'entrepôt ce qui a
permis également de dépanner pas mal et
les personnes du coin que savait pas
trop où aller ça évitait aussi toutes
les grandes que puisque au début tout le
monde se jeter dans les grandes surfaces
depuis trappe la quinzaine de livreurs
oeuvre donc pour les particuliers à
travers l'ile-de-france en 48 heures le
site internet a été repensé pour des
commandes en ligne
6000 ont été passés lors des quatre
dernières semaines et les locaux sont
ouverts ponctuellement au public
résidant à proximité
une solution qui a aussi permis d'éviter
de perdre 8 à 9 tonnes de marchandises
dans un premier temps mais aussi par la
suite de proposer des légumes on se dit
pour avoir une offre complète on veut
faire également du légume
donc on en faisait un petit peu mais là
on est très vite arrivée sur des volumes
assez important
donc on a
on avait des fournisseurs sur injuste
qu'on connaissait déjà bien sûr la
partie légumes on a traité
on l'a traité avec eux et on a commencé
à faire énormément de sachets de légumes
également c'est un des produits qui se
vendent le plus à la fin du confinement
l'entreprise pourrait maintenir son
activité en direction des particuliers
malgré le retour progressif des
abonnements d'entreprise lui aussi s'est
réorganisée pour rester ouverts en cette
période de confinement dans sa boutique
l'alchimiste l'artisan siro pied marque
chenu poursuit son activité pour faire
face notamment à une baisse importante
de son chiffre d'affaires le reportage
de mathilde et demi et de nicolas landry
c'est un alchimiste cyr au pied de la
vallée de chevreuse avec ses recettes il
fait face aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire
il poursuit la fabrication et la vente
de ces sirops mais a fermé son bar et
cesser toute animation d'ateliers
conséquence directe une perte de 40% de
son chiffre d'affaires au mois de mars
on a dû effectivement se réorganiser
puisqu'on est de 2 à travailler evelyne
et en chômage partiel
c'est comme ça qu'on a pu
travailler parce que sinon c'était
ingérable d'avoir de salaire
effectivement à temps plein ici
vu la baisse d'activité dans cette
nouvelle organisation marque chenu
travaille seul tous les jours de 7h à
22h
en temps normal près de 2000 bouteilles
sont produites en moyenne par mois avec
la crise sanitaire marque sony n'en
produit plus que mme il faut savoir que
pour arriver à comment dire à maintenir
le cap c'est à dire éviter la
catastrophe
j'ai pas dis à se développer d éviter la
catastrophe entre je travaille deux fois
plus pour deux formant d'argent donc que
j'ai fait appel effectivement des
producteurs locaux à des commerces
locaux pour pouvoir me fournis en
matière première ce qui a pu se faire
donc il ya une solidarité qui s'est mise
en place une solidarité aussi venant de
ses clients notamment à travers des
commandes sur internet
la principale source de son activité
aujourd'hui
face à la baisse de son activité marche
tenue a demandé aussi un recours au
fonds de solidarité et un
rééchelonnement des créances faut savoir
qu'une entreprise en général c'est 60 70
% de charge sa masse salariale
donc ça pas un effort au niveau des
charges beaucoup d'entreprises risquent
de péricliter
l'artisan estime aujourd'hui que les
charges salariales lui coûte près de
3000 euros par mois
c'est un nouveau motif dérogatoire pour
sortir de chez soi dans les prochains
jours après l'appel lancé par la spa il
sera possible à partir de jeudi et de
procéder à des adoptions la procédure se
fera uniquement en ligne
après avoir rempli un questionnaire et
échanger avec les équipes l'adoptant
pourra venir chercher son nouveau
compagnon le point et les explications
du président de la spa interrogé par
wilfrid richy
[Musique]
pour éviter tout contact nous proposons
un choix très choix de l'animal en
quelque sorte sur le site que le
questionnaire de de l'environnement
familial soit roupies également sur le
net
l'envoi d'une pièce d'identité puis
déplacement dont le refuge où les
salariés les bénévoles restent à une
dizaine de mètres de la personne que
l'on met seul à l'extérieur des
bâtiments avec l'animal si le fit ce
fait la suite de la procédure est la
même si ce n'est qu'on régularise
régularise pardon après l'ensemble de la
procédure qui n'est plus à ce moment-là
que purement administrative c'est ce
qu'on appelle un attendant celui vers un
pardon une adoption solidaire pour
lutter contre l'abandon excusez moi
c'est à dire que l'animal qui est pris
en adoption par la personne sauf deux
animaux celui avec lequel elle part mais
aussi celui qu'on va pouvoir récupérer
dans une fourrière et qui aurait été
irrémédiablement condamnés
[Musique]
le questionnaire est assez précis il est
assez long ont pu éventuellement avoir
un contact par téléphone ensuite si on a
besoin de renseignements complémentaires
je pense que si la personne
la vraie envie de prendre un animal et
qu'ensuite elle est conseillée par les
agents qui sont des professionnels de la
relation homme animal il n'y a pas de
raison que ça se passe mal nous avons
honte sur l'année moins de quatre bourgs
sont de retour de gens qui viennent
on a donné 43 mille animaux à l'adoption
l'an dernier d'un chiffre considérable
on a moins de 4% des gens qui reviennent
parce que finalement ils ont un souci
avec l'animal
on a eu vraiment peur il ya des
imbéciles qui sont amusés à diffuser
cette techno sur sur le net
il n'y a pas de communication du virus
par l'animal
on sait les gens ont réagi
intelligemment et avec prudence
on a toujours j'allais dire le même
nombre d'abandons que d'habitude mais il
n'y a pas eu d'augmentation sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour les 55
refuges dont les trois que nous avons
dans 78 nous sommes presque à saturation
c'est à dire que nous avons 90 %
d'occupation
sachant que nous devons garder une
petite marge de sécurité pour le cas ça
c'est produire en bretagne en début de
semaine dernière pour le cas où tous nos
salariés seraient malades en même temps
ce qui nous obligerait à évacuer nous à
niveau sur d'autres refusent un mot de
sport avant de se quitter on en revient
aux annonces présidentielles qui ont
établit l'interdiction de tout événement
avec du public nombreux jusqu'à la mi
juillet parmi les rendez-vous impactés
notamment le tour de france 2020 qui ne
pourra pas se tenir en l'état la 107e
grande boucle était prévue du 27 juin au
19 juillet avec une dernière étape au
départ des yvelines entre
mantes-la-jolie et les champs elysées à
paris plusieurs scénarios sont désormais
sur la table l'annulation du tour a été
écarté par l'organisateur est seul il ya
quelques jours
il faudra donc prouver un nouveau
créneau pour un report au mans l'été
voire en septembre nos confrères du
parisien avance la date du 25 juillet
l'équipe parle de la tenue de la
compétition au mois d'août le tour de
france cycliste passera en tout cas dans
les yvelines au minimum jusqu'en 2023
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité
restez chez vous et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]
il